I think it's safe to say that
rollerCoaster Tycoon 3 taught me some
great lessons in life one of which would
be the fact that foliage is damn [ __ ]
important in making things look great
and this is confirmed by this episode
and which I did realize that although I
lost a bit of hope for this park in some
places mostly the places that didn't
even have foliage yet I kind of regained
that hope but when i place the foliage
and it looks great and it might actually
update worthy and I think this park is
actually nearing completion it like kind
of in the same way as foliage makes
everything look better than you expected
it also makes everything look more
finished than you expected because it's
not that much of a job it doesn't take
that much time but it makes a huge
difference in how work in progress a
project looks and this is also one
reason why it is nice to sometimes do it
in a different way than I am doing
because there are kind of two main ways
to get around doing this in when it
comes to doing scenery and doing just
general foliage you can either this just
do like I do or at least in sections
where you play first place all of the
scenery and then go ahead and do the
foliage which is quite efficient and
it's nice and making layouts and stuff
like that not forgetting which kinds of
sets you use for foliage or the scenery
but then again it it's also not that
great as they knew it's very hard to
judge what the progress is on what
you're making for example sometimes when
I built Verona Valley for example I was
just working on it and that's also a ten
point then I lost confidence in my
project and I was like is this actually
the right direction and only when I
plays foliage in the end that I realize
how happy I actually was with the final
result but that was only until the very
end of the park when I added the foliage
and before that it's really hard to
judge whether everything is actually
going to turn out very nice and that's
why you might want to just build a bit
of foliage and built a bit of scenery
and just keep doing it hand
in hand and there are some pros and cons
to their various things of course when
you do foliage and scenery work at the
same time like I said you're well you're
kind of prone to losing certs it's kind
of easy to then if you're doing foliage
at the later stage for example you have
to look back at what sets you've used in
well the well yeah the past's it's
yourself has used and sometimes that's
kind of hard like I remember going back
to this park already and feeling like
well I don't exactly know which trees i
use do so first I had to study my own
work before I could actually get on with
my own work and that's one con to doing
the scenery in one go and then doing the
foliage in one go but it sometimes you
know it's also very nice to just save
that bit of time and just do everything
at once specialize in that stuff for a
bit and I think that it's actually
quicker to just do the scenery and one
go and then just do the foliage all over
the park but one more pro than I would
give to giving the not very specialized
way and just doing the scenery and a bit
of foliage a man a bit of scenery is
that it's arguably more fun sometimes
depends on what you used to work with
though but I find myself sometimes doing
it just because it's more fun more
variety in the kinds of things that
you're doing and I like that sometimes
but I rarely ever do it I didn't like
wreckage buster though which you could
have seen on the update threads on the
coaster I had some very work in progress
through pictures where one half of the
coaster was nearly completely finished
and the other half was just empty Crossy
fields and it did work in the end though
and it was a very fun project to work on
but then again it's not a very serious
example now is it it's just a joke
coaster after all and not really my best
one so it's not really something that
you can take seriously like that and I
don't know if there are any other
projects where I've kind of did that
thing with the foliage in the scenery
like that oh well I should probably talk
about what I'm doing right here well I
decided that I would add rock work to
this
as well because it obviously needs it we
need rock work everywhere because this
is an over-the-top park if this was
actually a real park I would actually
try to hold back on the rock work just a
tiny little bit you don't really have to
worry about making it natural or not
natural because as you might realize
most parks in real life use fake rocks
so you're not going to get realistic
rocks anyway so it are at least it's not
important to get realistic rocks anyway
but if you're building entire mountains
of course it's an entirely different
story and that is why this park is kind
of clashing and I just decided to do
that and then the motto of it's over the
top just go with it go with the flow or
don't and that's basically it for this
point it's either it's I either over the
top or I'm not going to going to do it
at all and same goes for this rock work
but I wouldn't necessarily say that this
is realistic but the point that I'm
trying to make is that your rock work
either has to be realistic if you want
some large rock work a lot of mountains
or a lakeside stuff like that and it
shouldn't be too over the top with many
small rocks and many different textures
that is not very realistic but if you're
going for a man-made look you can
actually do that as long as it's on a
somewhat small scale and it's doable
folks but for example I am look at
what's that Costa calling an expedition
everest knots a pretty big rock and it's
all man-made and you generally shouldn't
worry too much about rock work and it
being realistic or not it's generally it
can be either man-made or if it really
needs to be natural then only then do
you really have to well yeah be careful
with the rock work but sometimes it's
just fun to let yourself go in this take
all kinds of scenery and see what you
can do with that and that's kind of what
I did in this case although I must be
very honest I wasn't really too creative
with the rock work over here yes that is
a penis right there I was streaming and
then that was actually not a penis
because I like immature shapes but
because I wanted to create a little
camera
a little spot where I would have an open
area in the forest from which I could
take pictures or videos or just in
general my shots so that's why the penis
is over there it's a functional penis
don't worry what was I talking about
though then I think I completely lost
the subject well that's um that's a
problem isn't it I won't wait wait are
we talking about yeah the problem that I
felt with this park almost was as
over-the-top as a rock workmate might
seem it's not that creative but then
again there is a problem and you might
want to write this down because there's
just a very limited list of rock sets
out there there is Weber's foliage set
which got mossy rocks and a couple of
other things and they're very nice but
they only really work for Massey
environments forests and stuff like that
sometimes people use them for
Riverside's I guess that works waivers
large rocks which is generally like the
name suggests a set with large box when
you expect there's Weber's medium rocks
which unlike the name suggests has
completely different textures than large
rocks so do be wary of that and there is
shy guys rock set which is somewhat
outdated but it's still got some users
there is Yosemite set by MGP which got
those amazing big rocks that you can
really use for some mountain sides and
that is about it I think it's not really
much else out there that you can really
use some outdated sets and some sets in
which you have to create your own rock
faces but that takes a lot of time and
work and generally it's hard to come up
with some really unique rock faces
unless you actually make your own custom
scenery so but then again rock work is
not really something you should worry
too much about as long as you cover it
up with foliage you're good to go but
anyway that's it for this episode so
thanks for watching and see you on the
next one